you're watching the game spot co-op
stage sponsored by lego star wars the
force awakens we're back at the game
spot co-op stage here at e3 2016 hi
everybody hey right from ScrewAttack and
this is nick hello Danny hey what's up
Chad hey and we're here to talk about
all sorts of good stuff I think we're
just gonna play around on the white
boards though we got the white boards
out its genius idea uh we've talked
about Microsoft we've talked about Sony
mm-hmm we've talked about big surprises
we've talked about so not so big
surprises it's been it's been an
eventful day so far but one thing we
have not talked about so far is Nintendo
i I'm looking so great like right over
in this direction is it a Nintendo booth
yeah I just want to go over there and
play zelda the most amazing thing about
Nintendo is well they focus clearly on
really just two franchises right they're
like hey we're only focusing on Zelda or
end up like a week before like oh and
also we're gonna put some pokemon in
there right now yeah and some of them
will when they talked about that let's
talk about some of the moon first and
then we'll get into Zelda talk because I
hey because that's now I'm not gonna do
a Nintendo start with Zelda do a big ol
session of a Pokemon get everybody
disinterested and then come back we're
just gonna briefly touch on Pokemon
because the key here is Zelda so Pokemon
your big pokemons guy Danny do you play
pokemon no no mean I was wanting
Jigglypuff to come and sing and send
them all to sleep a whole time hashtag
buff the puffs yes that's the wall smash
brothers every day I had to do hashes on
this to make it not look like a wiener
jiggly puff looks like a smash bros care
sorry like a south park character could
say that you know that kind of does look
like a wiener still I'm this ass okay so
Nikki her big toe c'mon guy dad you've
played pokemon i said i was i played
religiously like red and blue and then I
played x and y and I played some along
the way too so I Nick you you really
absorbed everything in there and as a
guy who doesn't play pokemon who really
doesn't I don't really care about
Pokemon what what is something that
would bring me into the franchise that's
new between Sun and Moon ah you like why
well yeah but there's Hawaii which is
what the lolla islands if I remembering
the name correctly that's what they're
based on the region um gosh I think the
biggest thing that would have pulled you
in is like if you were intimidated by
like all the stats and the type
advantages disadvantages universally
amounts of knowledge so if that was for
whatever reason your hurdle then this
would be more inviting if that was not
your hurdle I don't see this one
bringing you in but gosh they covered a
lot of things but it could have been
done in like five minutes right like the
the menus are more improved in this oil
yeah like I was seeing that as I oh
that's that's nice but we spent like 10
minutes on it and also like the lighting
we talked about lighting in a Pokemon
game which fun fact it was you know
there was a light you could see things
happening there wasn't much to talk
about there but we spent so much time on
it anyway this is the new little things
nice little things that they did to make
things more efficient more less annoying
you know as somebody and his new pokemon
of course Danny here obviously like I
said he has no interest in Pokemon this
is great so it's all about 5050 here on
the stage um the things you're saying as
a non Pokemon player do nothing to get
me excited I a bit like the item at the
same time the stuff that you get excited
for like Call of Duty is stuff with
everybody else to say oh it's like so
little to hold me don't know but I'm
just gonna say it feels a little bit
like that where this time I'm the fan of
the franchise who's appreciating the
small incremental improvements and
you're just like whatever well menus
they never they never hype the new menu
system in call of duty no no is that
they never rang do you like adorable
kittens kittens are great I work on the
Internet aladdin's feel like fire fires
okay it's not on me as you like what if
he had it had every tire any farm yeah
I'm in late gonna be your first Pokemon
hash tag team Lytton that's the name
Linton which sounds like it's a stoner
cat but you know like
well so did that'll bring you in if
anything like 12 other Pokemon the shoot
fire yeah yeah yeah there's a ton of up
using suitable pokemon is he in a
Pokemon that's a cat that shoots fire
already yeah but this one you get to
start with also talks with nine tails
that shoots fire all right ilysm that
turns into a dragon didn't stop is the
pair of keys still in it yes grreat they
have not delayed I chandelure which is a
chandelier one there's a trash garbodor
a bit short of the stuff that we saw
from the new pokemon all right I know
people I go screw that guy hates Pokemon
I don't hate Pokemon I just I just never
really got into it no I am mad at you
right now for calling it pokemons there
it's pokemon pokemon yeah there's a
little thing okay uh what did you see
that like what you saw did it get you
excited for uh you know I really liked
X&Y it was my re-entry into the series
and so I'm still kind of riding that
train a bit I i think i would see myself
getting either sun or moon but neither
or both I'm not yeah not not both I mean
it's the same game differences are just
like the Pokemon you encounter god I'd
so let's get let's get to the real main
event now way I did I invented a new
Pokemon oh good well look Oh what do you
call it I want to I want to know if this
is what on Danny's about to look into
much people it's called span doors Oh
banner oh god no you guys call this
wrenches yeah really I was okay in in
pure Pokemon tradition we're gonna have
to change him for the Western market is
right sure I'm sure it's already
arranged mocha my cuz there's a there's
an l1 right uh probably yes I think
there is I think you know it'sit's gears
that's what years that it's like most
what shall we call it I've already
forgotten but I know it's there dear
door geard there that's probably cooler
than what they've got what did you droid
you all be googling that I'm drawing is
evolved know when you've drawn it looks
exactly like something that would be in
like banjo kazooie or just any game I
rare or play tonic these days upgrade
and you can become Spock it oh good
socket wrench it's more utilitarian I
guess all right let's get it thank you
thank you guys for your artist
renderings of the next Pokemon is its
next evolution is a scissor lift no can
you do that door sis yeah we already
have one called sizzle that's a heater
yeah you guys are it's a totally
different right now all right uh it's a
robot bug thing there's a problem you
can believe that see he believed that
they already had a scissor lift Pokemon
milk this one's all about it's a [ __ ]
white board o YT oh no we don't know God
anyway what's your next point grant yeah
Craig you're actually sitting on a
Pokemon right sorry just so far you guys
you guys have pissed off an entire
corner of the Internet today with I got
you I got you tongue oh yeah here you do
one eye and i'll do the other yeah hey I
got you wait wait wait give it a ton
give it a tongue you're watching live
gamespot score by itself looks like I've
done something to draw tongue but it
could be another function to talk to me
coming out of that guy all rights not
lead a normal in sun and moon no can we
don't you be afraid bring it down norman
reedus set let's bring it back alright
it's gamespot the hook stays dirty 3
2016 let's reset for a little bit hi I'm
Craig this is nick that's manny has a
pin of the internet and there's chatter
over this is Norman Reedus Norman are
you serious with this with his various
on the white dress my boss is the baby
now we are talking int into a Norman
Reedus as always always we we are here
to talk about Zelda now yeah let's be
real there a reason why people tuned in
to nintendo and rest of the way now for
those you guys watching on the
ScrewAttack youtube channel i have a
pull up for you right now i don't know
what you guys think about this is this
very it's a very intense pole and this
is going to decide the fate of the
internet the question is zelda will be
or Zelda breath of the wild will be
worth the wait a game but not a game
changer right uh mediocre or uh
pcmasterrace whoo which i think much i
expect that to win but that's
so vote I want to know what you guys
legitimately think about the new zelda
game which is great alright so Zelda I
know like very little about this game
outside of because I haven't played it
yet but right any I understand you have
have you played this and I know watch
people play I've watched the boat watch
yeah I have it all but what on the stage
yesterday so I saw somebody paying let
me tell you what I know about Zola
there's a giant line that is about eight
hours long it was right around before
they opened up yeah yours yeah the
exhibitors have lined up like beforehand
just to get in and play because have you
looked in there it says oh hey Bill I
feel like made Hyrule and I just want to
go up to the look I get it I'm not gonna
get to play the game cuz there's way too
many people can I just hang out in here
like I just want to hang out in Hyrule
like you're not even allowed to see it
because I'm there you have this big
white wall just in like encasing the
whole thing in your past in tennis with
mr. doesn't Bend like open so you can
see in yeah not so this year there's a
hundred of new screens and I think if
they would have brought 500 screens the
winnaman enough Riley's no I got gravity
170 God 170 playable stations of Zelda
and there's not enough there's not
enough like the line literally I
remember is my 10th III fly first III
was 2006 and the longest line i ever saw
was for the week Brian it was it was a
six-hour line and it was our first viral
video for ScrewAttack we did twelve
thousand views right and it was a big
deal and and I walked it and the whole
video was like a minute 45 seconds sted
up to katamari damacy right yeah it does
and it was I remember getting the line
the in the line there and I was like how
long they say and the guy said like six
hours but the line here it's like way
longer rights in the wheel I'm
ridiculous and this is we're talking
about a singular game not a console yeah
yeah for the Wii U of all things yeah
yeah which is crazy cuz I mean look the
wii u and it's clear it's clearly third
place right now and then your arms of
sales figures everything across the
board so they are the other thing I know
about Zelda it's coming out on both the
wii u and the NX yeah right which they
did that with twilight princess yes they
sure did so I mean everybody's gonna
wanna get the NX one that sounds like
when you got the gamecube version of
twilight princess she knows like who
would not me anything is there going to
be not launching them simultaneously
sleep right so both on the wii u and the
NX at the same day on the same time in
the first quarter of 2017 or march
ashrafieh yeah Inger scroll next comes
out in March and like I I know they said
they were gonna be talking about NX here
but I'm seeing myself you really you're
sure you don't want to talk about your
new console the e3 right before it love
why do they know to like why do they
really need to because you notice nobody
knows anything about any cares because
you know that at any second Nintendo can
go hey Nintendo Direct tomorrow and they
have 500,000 people watch I want to know
how many teraflops it has compared to
the three projects cordial mix is the
amount of teraflops to beat that is the
standard yeah like I think for consumers
they really like yes it is a massive
shame that i'm showing it this year i
guess they can do to direct it is a big
like the fanfare of e3 is obviously an
important thing but even worse than that
is like it's not like Nintendo or I have
all of the third parties around all the
time yeah this is one of the times where
they actually get to have those meetings
that's a lot of what III is about so
like if we're nine months hours I mean
the third party support has never been
wonderful anyway right if they're not
having conversations with you know I'm
sure they are with some of the bigger
ones but like with it everyone I begged
their new platform like that's that's
worrisome thing well they they had to
have those conversations but they just
aren't talking publicly about I mean
they have to be out of those
conversation well I'm thought you
remember with the wii u a bunch of a
support pulled out like EA EA p yeah
they were one of the big ones initially
it's like yeah we're gonna support the
wii u and then they're like nevermind
yeah go for it ubisoft ubi us give it
the game they gave it an honest shot but
yeah at some point they saw had what
items from though is like you know
seeing like will they do new console and
you say you don't need to but like i
need just most of us were all like
diehard old-school gamers and we want a
nintendo to have a win and III it
forever absolutely they did a thing that
where people walked away they were just
like yeah yeah like you know and that's
why I think this might be it no I mean
yeah which people went in critical of
Nintendo's saying they're gonna focus on
one game what the hell are they thinking
and then they come in they go oh I gotta
wait ten hours okay I see what they're
thinking I know it makes sense Nintendo
it's gonna sound really crazy but
Nintendo may have won by bringing one
game like to e3 which is crazy pencil
what you're judging it by all right
I feel like I would judge I would judge
winning III by interest right and i
think that there's no there's no other
product here that has a line like that
and you're right you're doing absolutely
right room like a consult still a lot of
people haven't bought yeah i play wii u
i play it once every three months maybe
a pizza mario kart last week that was
alright i'm not even like a massive like
zelda fat like i grew up playing
commodore games in or if I didn't know
in a Nintendo I wasn't one of those like
I think winwaker was the first one I
bought and I've played a bunch since but
like even like me watching this this is
like actually were when I got out of it
was it got real fallout five out of us
cuz he emerges from the cave and it's
like that feeling in 43 when you come
out of the vault and like better you
know have fun yeah like that's what it
kind of felt like and then the game
played it looks like well it's crazy
that's actually talk about the game
bi-courtney they said that they were
like we've kind of totally broken zelda
out of what it's ever been born they had
and you hear that a lot about guys like
oh we're all we've done this we've done
such different things and it still feel
similar this looks slightly different i
yes yes survival exploration you can see
in the gameplay there's a temperature
gauge there's like a gauge boy that
tells you like how much noise you make
is like stealth is an element you can
take maudlin sticks and beat them with
it yeah you please Amelia craft things
you cook food you set the forest on fire
make like I was like that it's like
showing I guess they wanted to show like
how interactable everything is but it's
just like and you know look he's doing
this he's doing this and then there's
one shot and links just burning the
forest it was something better like I I
was catching up on some the gameplay
that I missed right before we went live
here and there was wind blowing like
crazy I don't know who's the environment
or if late cause that but he threw a
stick or no you actually he just chopped
down like a small tree next to a
campfire the wind blows the tree
branches into the fire and it pushes it
through this grass so this does this
huge line of fire and then there's some
make an explosive barrel off to the side
it blew that up which made it even worse
the stands there's like I've made a
horrible mistake you just turns and runs
the other way yeah but you can jump now
there's he a dozen jump like no big
lots of God zzz elda too yeah and
climate uh but more interesting than
that to me was how they introduced link
because the every zelda game starts
backing up oh yeah yeah voice acting but
every zelda game starts with him waking
up that's a tradition that they've
actually kept by this time he's waking
up and our co-workers called it weapon x
yeah it's like wolverine like he's
laying in a pool of liquid and like we
like you know seeps away and Link wakes
up claws come out of his hands you know
yeah yeah i saw people from the screw
attack office tweeting that he was like
weapon x her weapon l and i thought does
he have claws but then i saw what they
were talking about like it's like doom
guy all over again he's just like Oh
from the sarcophagus yeah it start
tutoring everything it's like this weird
a mixture of nature and technology cuz
like you see even in the trailer from
last year he pulls out this bow and the
arrow like transformers I'll kind of
like shape-shifts doesn't he like how is
it runes or something like yeah
basically magical bit yeah yeah and you
have this uh this tablet the sheikah
slate that's the the big mechanic he's
using like pinpoint places on your map
so link has a tablet yeah exactly you
know the most objects the most
fascinating thing to me about this zelda
as a whole but uh and i keep I keep what
i call it the breath breath of fire but
it's not ice during the demo oh yeah
yeah i think it's a natural thing you
know but ok so the most husband-to-be is
a wonder of its tune there there
obviously there's a lot of similarity
yeah is it two different right what is
it two different will it scare off the
trees elder traditionalist or will they
embrace it fully you know and that's
that's the thing is when you look at it
we're looking at starting adding
temperature and weather elements yeah
there's a lot of mechanics at play here
but one thing that they kept mentioning
like in this footage of watching right
here is they kept drawing comparisons to
the original nes game I wanted to make
it feel like that game in that you just
kind of explore go wherever you want
figure out what you're allowed to do now
versus what you have to come back and do
later once you have a new tool a new
weapon there something like
and I think a lot of the ways they've
done that is with you know they use the
temperature gauge and stuff like there's
some really snowy places where it's too
cold so unless you have gear that
prepares you for the cold you can't
survive it long enough and that's one
way that they you know encourage
exploration versus you know coming back
later so a potential solution this if
they do it I don't know CD Projekt RED
business with Witcher when they
originally created the witcher it's like
it's a lot to manage like you're
technically you're constantly like dying
basically you need to be mixing the
right potions and taking them all the
time or you're going to lose and they
realize that was a little too hardcore
for people so on different difficulty
settings they don't have that right now
that's like the most hardcore of options
is you really have to manage all that
stuff but if you don't want to you just
play on like a normal difficulty or
something so they might do some of that
stuff because again like Nintendo is
always very like family friendly and
keeping up stuff in mind and if there's
too much stuff to juggle in my audience
also i don't know i don't know if
they'll do that but it also might be
really minor like just like you're
saying like they've always juggled
temperature by like if you you couldn't
go into the volcano unless you wore your
red tunic you know so they might it
might just be like smaller things like
that most fascinating was i saw some
gameplay yesterday where they were up in
the time a temperature in general you
can change your tunic as you go from
place to place and your words down to
yeah you can step out here highly in
boxers yeah yeah where you start but
there was a part where he where link got
to a you know a snowy mountain and he's
like actually shipping he was
legitimately shivering his body clammed
up like he was really cold and you would
they were switching between the tunics
to where you know you obviously had to
put it on to where he could actually
survived it like that the way it was
more than just tunics though it was like
the shirt and the pants the boots i'm
assuming there's gonna be a hat at some
point don't anything like it has to be a
hat force academy but it did shown so
much like I I'm almost wondering if they
may be shown too much really almost i
mean like we've seen how dare you like
i'm happy to see it all but just uh the
oh I'm every time I look over at the
stream they're showing something I
haven't seen before because i feel like
the list is this long it's not exciting
i think that's really exciting no it's
very exciting when you were why
mr. day I want to be able to discover
that much and more on my own when you
were watching it you were saying like is
that the Temple of Time like anyway
decide Temple of Time text as you
approached it see that's crazy that's
great yeah I think about like will they
will they think they said them during
their during the nintendo direct or
their the press commerce whatever you
want to call it was weird about to show
a portion of this a tiny perfect and the
portion that they showed has been Giants
and the fact oh my gosh yes like nobody
will be able to explore this entire
weekend and this is just a tiny
fortunately it's it's mind-blowing
really cool yeah they haven't shown very
many characters like it's been linked
and some goblins and an old man which
people are hypothesizing is Gannon but
this all really yeah yeah you know Mount
Doom or whatever in the better when I'm
you know that but I not mountain deal I
know def mountain Death Mountain that's
what is I'm wrong fantasy oh I know go
Lord of the Rings with it goes the other
way yeah yeah Sauron you know as I was
original but uh yeah no I'm I'm really
really interested to explore the game I
hope you get to be a pona but i'll get
to at least get adobe nipomo just get to
be the horse why not um well you get to
know you'd certainly get to be on her
because those in the original trailer
Yeah Yeah right for sure um but yeah
just a lot to explore and I'm looking
forward to the first like only boxers
playthrough they could call it breath
and wild and I yeah yeah bottom line hi
rules have been a world that everybody
loves exploring in video games and this
is looks like the most immersive one of
them all so I can't wait just if nothing
else just run around my room yeah what
if because we saw the temple of time
they take a page from hockey right on
time and instead of going from a kid to
adult link you go from adult lake to
super old lake into the end you just got
this really awesome beard and you're
just like a wizard like it would
actually be pretty cool right yeah to
see really mature link as opposed to
think maybe they are showing loads but
maybe the hope is that like that's
because I've got so much more to show
yeah yeah so who knows well so I have
the Twitter poll once again if you're
watching on ScrewAttack you you if you
watch on ScrewAttack youtube channel you
have a pole in the upper corner over
there if you hit the I button the pole
is very simply zelda breath of the wild
will be our
worth the wait okay a great game but not
a great but not a game changer mediocre
or complete and total failure pc master
race right of those selections let's
actually just go down the line and see
what you guys feel about that Nick the
first one I mean it's they're showing a
lot of the open-world aspects a lot of
that stuff we've seen in other games
before but we know that this is a Zelda
game so it's going to come with all the
dungeons and the item gathering stuff
that we know and love and it's going to
be this one big happy amazing mixture of
great ideas that's really optimistic yes
yes I I'm loving what I'm seeing so far
Danny I think the same I think what's
happened with any are from the outside
looking in as well as somebody's not a
massive zelda fan what what Nintendo
seed you'll be doing its elder for the
past couple of years has been doing a
lot of like safe bets like reissues of
older games and like games that are you
know very similar to ones that have come
at a previous they you know like the DF
stuff looks a lot like winwaker and the
spirit jacks on like it's all kind of
within the like family of known
quantities so hopefully that means that
this is like a playpen for them to just
do whatever the hell they want so i
think they're going for and whenever
Nintendo does that they always make a
classic even if it's something like
ocarina which are not green alike am
majora's mask which are people somebody
it's divisive you know the Austin they
took a big punch at one of the games I
feel it was my galaxy and it was
absolutely tremendous game so yeah and
that and that's exactly what I was gonna
say like it may be a little scary that
they're doing so many things different
well you said every time Nintendo does
this it's awesome like I mean people
freaked when they found out Mario was
gonna go into 3d 64 and it's regarded as
one of the best mario games like I mean
I I'm really excited to see what they do
and I they're gonna head another park
another one of those fascinating things
to me is to think about this game was
actually supposed to be out already
right yeah there's a game that was
relieved they'll schedule for released
in 2015 and think about how much they
initially was i believe they now still
have 15 right and then they believe so
okay but figure out how much they've
changed their e3 strategy each I think
these companies they think two years
three years ten years in advance
sometimes as far as you know their
forecast games their development such
and how much they must have changed
their e3 strategy coming into
you know just in the last few months
since they announced it was going to be
delayed at the end of 2015 so it's just
crazy to think about yeah maybe it's
finished and they're just waiting for
the NX yeah babe zaharias touching it up
what do you guys think sit like the next
three three months how soon do you think
we'll know anything about the NX when's
TGS that is september-october so that's
probably the next big opportunity so
they'll probably do a direct around then
they'll do it direct but they're going
to want to have a chance for them to act
for like press to get their hands and
tender never goes to TGS they never do
they don't do stuff on the floor anymore
yeah I don't do something separate yeah
they're like their own little separate
thing I've got to switch to just directs
now so I mean apart from that all there
is is pax Wes than gamescom I'm like
Nintendo go to gamescom but they're not
gonna show the NX I don't do their kind
of an annex at Gamescom I think I think
the best way to do it is they should
just hold a hold of Nintendo Direct I
mean that's the best way to do it that's
why I'm intended a 3 is what it is
because people haven't you have a direct
outlet to to your consumer now it
depends how weird it is because if it's
something like the wii they spend a lot
of time and money like doing tours of
like shopping malls yeah i get to get
people's huh so if the NX is just
unknown quantity if it's a
familiar-looking controller and all that
then they can just like push it out
there but like after TGS there's nothing
until like what like pax east is in
water anywhere and you're even looking
from that it's like there's nowhere to
show this triangle so you know what you
know what uh they'd probably host her
own events right yeah you know you know
I really hope Nintendo brings back next
year hop the Nintendo World Championship
let's make that happen in tune oh yeah
haha what about space world hey there's
no yeah I remember eating that really no
power alright so a little intendo talk
for you guys coming up next we're gonna
do a little bit of VR the VR is the big
thing we're talking be our next CR and
grappling hooks that's rapidly alright
cool live from the game spots co-op
stage here on the floor at e3 2016 we
will be right back
you